well if you look carefully you'll see
subtle signs of decay throughout our
society Starbucks for one example
recently announced that going forward
its seats and bathrooms will be open to
non paying customers that's bad news if
you want to bring your kids there pretty
good news if you're a vagrant meanwhile
in New York a couple had to evict their
30 year old son from their basement
because he refused to move out when he
defended his decision to live there
forever micro is the host of the TBN
show somebody's got to do it the latest
season of that will debut soon he just
spoke to us about these stories and how
they may be connected here it is joining
us tonight micro good to see you Mike
Tucker how are you couldn't be better
but bewildered and maybe you can clear
this up
Starbucks announcing you no longer have
to buy anything to lounge around its
stores or use the bathroom meanwhile 30
year olds are suing to stay in their
parents basements are these stories
connected do they tell us something
bigger about where the country is going
dogs and cats living together
look I personally I'm in the midst right
now of doing what I do every year which
is try and give away work ethic
scholarships it gets harder every year
so I mean it gets harder to give away
money we've given away $5,000 five
million dollars over the last five years
and yes every year it gets increasingly
difficult to affirmative ly reward work
ethic there's some things
my scholarship requires you to do that
other scholarships don't you have to
write essays and make videos and sign a
sweat pledge and when people are often
confronted with these hoops through
which I ask them to leap they take what
you call umbrage at that and I find it I
find it fascinating it doesn't bother me
so much because I understand that a
valuable thing is almost always a thing
that's in demand and work ethic is very
much in demand but to answer your
question why is it harder to find it I
think that probably does have something
to do with the expectations that have
evolved out of the safe space movement
which you've done a lot to talk about on
your program and I'm starting to think
that maybe there is a link between the
expectations a patron might have in a
Starbucks visa vie the expectations a
squatter who just happens to be
genetically tied to you might have visa
vie the basement in which he currently
dwells etc etc you know I mean of all
the divides in the country I think you
could probably make a pretty interesting
case that there's a fissure running
through the expectation of what happens
when we elevate safety and feelings to a
level of primacy I think it creates a
real disconnect that people are
struggling the partial wait a second are
you saying that safety isn't the most
important thing ever I'm saying that
everybody wants to go home safe at the
end of the day safety always would be a
delightful bromide a wise platitude
safety first is the stuff of idiocy it
allows us to begin to believe that
somebody other than us might care more
about our well-being than we do and the
minute we buy into that nonsense then we
embrace the warm grip of complacency so
know Safety's not the enemy but if you
make it the priority then let's just
wrap ourselves in bubble pack and drive
at speeds approaching five miles an hour
and never assume anything that could
ever be confused with risk that is
really deep when you say safety first
you're a suit no I'm I'm this is one of
the many on articulated assumptions that
govern our society and no one ever
examines them in the light of day and
you just did so when you say say explain
that little bit more and you say safety
first you're assuming that someone out
there cares more about your well-being
than you do mm-hmm
yeah I'm saying that on dirty jobs my
crew and I sat through over a hundred
mandatory safety briefings and through
the first couple of seasons they were
very effective because we listened like
this we were very concerned we were in a
dangerous hostile on
environment but over time the big safety
first placards and the mandatory boxes
that you have to check and the lockout
tagout procedures these things start to
sound like the teacher in Charlie Brown
right its wah wah wah wah wah
and you stop listening so the unintended
consequence of telling you that nothing
is more important than your safety is
the very dynamic that leads people to
walk across Fifth Avenue when the little
man says walk instead of looking both
ways exactly it's not a coincidence that
the most dangerous intersections in the
world are intersections that have signs
that tell you when to walk so again
we've talked about this with the minimum
wage we've talked about it with a lot of
different things but the unintended
consequences of magnifying a virtue to a
place it doesn't deserve to occupy will
always come back to kick us in the
throat really deep so are there new are
there safety briefings on your new show
you've got one of the biggest digital
shows that's ever been how much safety
is in that show well safety like I said
is always present everything I've done
dirty jobs somebody's got to do it
returning the favor I mean we always
focus on going home in one piece but
part of doing that in my world is to say
safety third now that's controversial
that makes people go what are you
talking about what's more important than
safety and now suddenly you're having a
conversation about something that will
ultimately rebound to personal
responsibility safety third is just a
way of cutting through the warm milk and
the soft tissue that makes everybody
comfortable when I say everybody I mean
actuarial accountants I mean HR I mean
insurance adjusters you've done it how
many times you got on a plane you know
and been told by the pilot that the most
important thing is to get you home in
one piece just once I'd like the pilot
to say hey look sit back and relax cuz I
love my wife and my kids or my husband
and my daughters and I'm gonna get
myself home in one piece
have fun strap yourself in for the ride
you've never been in better hands adios
exactly and by the way you can't control
your life anyway the plane goes down
players all you got so like let's Pete
let's stop lying and but and also joy
and achievement are more important than
safety anyway
I grow that was that was great it was
great to see you thank you